There is that quote, "Curiosity is the spark behind the spark of every great idea."
And you'll find curiosity right here in Frisco.
No one should feel limited because of their age.
Anika Chebrolu was 14 years old, a 9th grader at Independence High School.
She loves art, loves dancing Indian classical,...
...but her biggest triumph just might be in science.
She just won the National 3M Young Scientist Challenge,...
...used a software method to find a molecule...
...that could open the door for a therapy for COVID-19.
So, stopping that protein,...
...would be able to stop the virus from entering and infecting host cells,...
...which makes it very effective and important drug target.
And at just 14, she knows more than most.
It's work she started when she was in 8th grade at Nelson Middle School,...
...pivoted from influenza to COVID-19...
...when she saw what the virus was doing to her community.
That molecule she found: more than 50 letters long.
Scientists call the house about it.
She has more than 300 interview requests.
This week, she got an offer from a college,...
...but today, she offers you good advice.
Because no question is a bad question,...
...so make sure you stay curious and keep on asking questions.